I think it's worth extending that
discussion for a minute because there's
so much anger and hatred and divisive
Naseem politicization of wealth out
there today that it's it's worth talking
about where the actual sanity for a
second I mean I could rant and yell and
scream about it and flap my arms like
everybody else does but let's just talk
about it for a minute let's just talk
this through number one when you vilify
and make successful people did you hear
me cheering her on she makes a million
seven she's 31 years old hear me
cheering her on I'm proud of her she
started with nothing okay I don't even
understand how they did that I didn't
get in the details of where that money
came from but oh my goodness what an
amazing young couple now you've got
about three options when you run into a
story like that and you run into them at
a distance you read an article about
them you know someone across town they
live on the other side of the tracks I
grew up on the other side of the tracks
great neighborhood we weren't poor but
we weren't rich blue-collar families
most of them one generation off the farm
come into the suburbs of Nashville it
was the kind of neighborhood you could
get your butt busted in anybody's house
and they call your mama and tell you did
you get busted again when you get home
we all loved each other
good neighborhood that's where I grew up
I started with nothing Sharon I were
millionaires by the time we were 26
years old
we owned four million dollars for the
real estate at 3 million those were the
debt the debt was stupid and short-term
90 day notes the bank got sold called
our notes we spent the next two and a
half years of my life losing everything
we owned with a brand-new baby a toddler
and a marriage hanging on by a thread we
got the opportunity to be bankrupt to
start over at 28 so I'm so stupid I've
not only been a millionaire I've been a
man here twice and now I'm a
multi-millionaire the second time I
don't I mean death this time not stupid
enough to do it the other way twice but
I did it did it stupid some people are
smart enough they can do it only once so
when you hear a story or you see someone
the got a nice car
you see even a music person I know
people don't usually attack the music
people you certainly don't attack the
Hollywood types when they make a
bazillion dollars but it's like when
regular people make a bazillion dollars
particularly the evil business people
they must be evil evil you have three
possible things you can react it when
you see someone else that is doing well
financially
number one you can be you can cheer them
on because you want to be them someday
or you already are them and you're just
celebrating with them that they're a
rockstar young couple that's me
you can say wow I'm 39 I'm not making
that kind of money but in that cool that
they did that and I'm gonna go do what
I'm supposed to do at my life so that I
can do well I'm gonna live like no one
else so later I can live like no one
else I can I can get in the same river
that they're swimming in and swim with
them downstream with the current I'm
gonna brag on them and celebrate with
them when you do that it number one it
makes you rare because most people can't
do that they don't have the character to
do it but number two it sets you up for
success because you're not hating
success if you hate successful people
it's very hard for you to want to become
a successful person because you don't
want to hate yourself it's called
cognitive dissonance it's a
psychological concept you don't want to
become the thing you hate and so if you
hate successful wealthy people
and that's all you say about wealthy
people then why would you ever want to
become one of those people it's
cognitive dissonance it's incompatible
in your value system so it's very
difficult for you to become successful
financially when you hate successfully
financially successful financial people
so that one one option is to cheer and I
urge you to please get in that camp
cheering cheer you see someone else
winning go man so proud for you even if
you're not there yet and there's a
little tinge of man I wish it was me
good then go make it you baby or go to a
tenth of that I mean hundred seventy
thousand a year wouldn't be
about income you know I mean tenth of
that's not bad the second thing you can
do is you can be jealous you can say man
man oh man I wish I was like that I wish
I was like that
I want what they've got I want to be
like that I'll never get there but I'm
not the little man can't get ahead I'm
stuck people like me people that grew up
where I grew up people that do what I do
people with my political persuasion my
skin color my sex my I'm a victim and
Condoleezza Rice says when you declare
yourself a victim of prejudice you have
given someone else power over your life
take the power for your own life so
don't be jealous jealous says I want
what you have but I don't think I can
get it it's evil you know it's more evil
than jealousy jealousies big ugly
brother Envy
that's their third option you could be
cheering them on you can be jealous
worst thing you could do I got all a
bunch of people in our culture doing
this you can be envious envious is not
only jealousy I want what you have and I
don't think I can have it but envious is
I want what you have I don't think I can
have it so I don't want you to have it
and this is the wealth inequality
movement we're gonna attack success and
successful people I don't think you
should have that and so I'm going to
embrace socialism where they take it
away from you or Anarchy where they take
it away from you now 1% evil people who
know the world
the little people can't get ahead little
people get ahead every day 11 million
millionaires and 91% of them are first
generation rich in America started with
nothing little people get ahead every
day I'm so dumb I was little people came
from that side of the tracks I told you
I'm so dumb I had to do it twice don't
tell me it can be done
well you had this privilege and that
privilege and that privilege yeah but I
don't have any hair and I'm from the
south and some of you Yankees think
everybody from the South's dumb which
just indicates how dumb you are
anytime you're stereotyped someone to
indicate your stupidity some of you
people think we broadcast this thing
from a double-wide because I have a
southern accent
dadgum nice double-wide in there folks
talking to the live audience outside but
seriously guys I mean think about how we
react to wealth we have vilified success
let me help you with this if you make
$34,000 a year you're in the top 1% of
income earners in the world if you make
$34,000 a year you likely have a
flat-screen TV and two cars you are in
the top 1% of the world the rest the
world should be hating on you based on
the wealth inequality movement think
this through guys I listen I don't want
anybody be poor I don't anybody to hurt
but the best way to help someone who's
struggling financially is not to take
money away from someone else the best
way to helps someone who's struggling
financially is hey let's learn from
those who aren't struggling financially
do what they do and become one of them
you get to decide that you have the
power of choice right now are you a
victim or a victor
be a cheerleader for the successful be a
cheerleader for successful people
because you want to be one of them
if you cheer them on you're swimming in
the same river they're swimming in and
you're swimming right beside them